nous partons en eure et loir dans les
ateliers d'une toute petite entreprise
familiale atypique qui s'est spécialisé
dans les éclairages led un secteur
pourtant très concurrentiel pour s'en
sortir
elle mise sur la qualité et le
développement durable et ça marche
arnaud moreau est à l'aise dans cet
atelier seulement cinq personnes elles
conçoivent assemble et test des
éclairages led
cette entreprise peut paraître désuète
artisanale et pourtant elles vont s'est
produit dans la france entière
son mot d'ordre qualité et durabilité
nous on travaille encore avec vraiment
du métal pour bien refroidir les puces
etc des choses qui ne vont pas s'user
donc en fin de vie ou peux me redonner
mon spot change la puce qui est la
partie qui sait user je vous redonne le
même spot
il n'ya pas d'observer sans ce programme
et est malheureusement aujourd'hui la
majorité des produits led sont tout
plastique et tout jetable c'est à dire
que baho premiers composants qui lâche
on jette un ensemble
cette équipe a des airs de dernier
village gaulois à l'heure où les
éclairages led inondent le marché
elle s'adresse avant tout à des
particuliers en personnalisant ses
propositions vous non plus confié leur
plan les plans de leur cuisine
généralement leur demande où vont être
positionnés les meubles et nous on va
les conseiller dans l'implantation des
luminaires marilyn accompagnée de sa
soeur véronique a repris la structure
familiale ayant 37 ans d'existence
spécialisé dans les éclairages allogènes
l'entreprise s'est converti au led il y
a huit ans ce petit comité nécessite que
chacun soit multi tâches tout le monde
se sont donc entièrement impliquée dans
les projets même quand y'a un nouveau
produit qui sort ils passent et le
prototype passe par toutes les étapes
dans l'entreprise si on me propose un
spot on dit ah que j'essaye de le monter
les ballons ça c'est pas possible ou ça
prend trop de temps ou et c'est un
toutes les pièces et les optiques ont
été conçus en interne
même les moulages les prix sont près de
deux fois plus cher que pour des
produits équivalents proposée par la
grande distribution
un choix mais cette petite entreprise a
trouvé son public
c'est un petit peu plus cher à nous
d'être inventifs pour que nos spots
demande le moins de temps d'assemblage
possible donc là c'est dans la
conception de produits pour que les le
câblage se fasse rapidement de manière à
limiter la partie où nous sommes un peu
désavantagé par rapport à d'autres pays
qui n'ont pas les mêmes charges
quand en france avec environ 1600 unités
produites par mois
l'entreprise vise actuellement un marché
de niche la tendance est aujourd'hui aux
produits moins chers et donc plus
rapidement usées néanmoins marilyn et
son équipe croit que les consommateurs
soucieux de l'environnement seront de
plus en plus nombreux nous sommes
toujours en eure-et-loir havok cette
fois ci au beau milieu de la beauce
s'est dissipée s'élancer est l'un des
sites de l'entreprise carreman thinel
produits 148 tonnes de pommes de terre
chaque année vous les retrouvez en
sachet dans le supermarché
bonjour talipot pagny chante vous êtes
l'une des rétros stable du site alors la
particularité c'est que les producteurs
de pommes de terre
ce sont aussi leurs actionnaires alors
par martin est en relation directe avec
le milieu agricole et à partir
socialement à 2 160 producteurs
actionnaires moi ça fait nous
d'entreprise ce avait 12 ans de travail
etc et même producteur sur le site gpon
avec vous la partie administrative à peu
près une soixantaine de salles arrive et
c'est un chiffre en augmentation ou ça
reste stable
super l'augmentation pour répondre à
tous les envieux aujourd'hui est en
période de récolte ont amené à avoir
beaucoup
salariée a saisonniers puisqu'on a eu
également une suite de travaux agricoles
qui permet de planter le but est de
récolter les bars de bien tourner au
producteur à l'entreprise été créé par
un groupe entre du père il ya maintenant
une bonne vingtaine d'années
à l'origine ces produits de fer était
orienté sur le marché l'industrie et ont
décidé de revenir sur le marché du fret
est là elle a bossé un territoire qui
est propice à la production des terres
la côte pourquoi la bouche parce que
c'est un père noir qui nous assure une
qualité et une richesse des terres
agricoles
avec une production en face une qualité
qui répondent à toutes les exigences
qualitatives de nos clients aujourd'hui
alors ça te sont des pommes de terre ont
été récoltés clan alors ça ici c'est la
récolte 2010 est une plage ont été
récoltés entre le mois d'août et
d'octobre 2010 est actuellement on se
prépare à la plantation à c'est une
année plutôt compliquée du fait du
printemps très humide et très pluvieux
on a beaucoup de mal à faire venir dans
les parcelles
logiquement on aurait commencé à planter
ça s'étale du 20 mars jusqu'à fin avril
début mai alors les pommes de terre qui
sont récoltées pas sur des terrains à
l'arrivée du chant sont moins calibré
puis stockés dans nos hôpitaux à des
températures pour permettre le maintien
du tubercule jusqu'à au mois de juin de
l'année suivante
et elle
notre armure la consommation de pommes
de terre a baissé en france l'an dernier
la consommation mondiale elle devrait
augmenter dans les dix prochaines années
une bonne nouvelle pour l'entreprise pas
menti qui exporte un tiers de sa
production